hello grammarians in this video I'm
going to tell you about a piece of
punctuation called the semicolon which
basically looks like a comma with a
period on top of it the semicolon has a
few uses but the basic sort of standard
use is to link to closely related ideas
that can stand on their own as
individual sentences so that might sound
a little weird you think there's two
individual sentences so they just have a
period in between them why why do they
need to be linked well let's look at an
example and I'll show you what I mean
I'm a big fan of rollercoasters but if I
weren't I could say something like I
don't want to ride the mega sky coaster
I'm afraid of heights and that ride
sounds terrifying
now you notice we have a semicolon here
in between these parts but let's take a
step back and just put a period here for
a second so now we have I don't want to
ride the mega sky coaster period I'm
afraid of heights and that ride sounds
terrifying exclamation point these can
work on their own as different sentences
but they're so closely tied together you
know I say I don't want to ride the mega
sky coaster it's sort of telling us the
back story as to why I don't want to
ride it so we can use a semicolon in
this instance to sort of tie the two
sentences together into one now we can't
go around tying every sentence to each
other we can't have everything just
connected with a whole bunch of
semicolons it works in this case because
these clauses are sharing such similar
information in this sentence the two
clauses that are directly connected are
both independent clauses this makes
sense because the semicolons job is to
connect things that can stand on their
own as sentences but a sentence isn't
always just an independent clause by
itself one example of this would be I
want to get a pet turtle semicolon
however I think it might scare my baby
brother this is an independent clause
and so is this
but the however in between the two of
them can make things a little bit
confusing that's why it's important to
note that you can have a semicolon
followed by an introductory adverb or a
transitional phrase it doesn't just have
to be independent clause semicolon
independent clause period you can have
other clauses and phrases and words in
there as long as the things that you're
linking together can stand on their own
as individual sentences there's another
place we can use semicolon
which is in a complex list in this case
it's called a super comma but we're
going to get to that in another video
so for now this is how you use a
semicolon to link parts of a sentence if
the words to the left and the words to
the right of the semicolon can stand as
individual sentences with a period in
between them you can put a semicolon
there instead you can learn anything
page out